the inefficiencies in supply chain
are back pressure holding back all the
other world's industries every industry
depends on it
employment jobs prosperity is really
held back by a
rotten or at least dilapidated
infrastructure for global logistics
flexport's one of the most important
companies out there trying to improve
this trying to
almost like do open-heart surgery on the
world's circulatory system with the
economy
a company that's been on my radar for a
few years is called flexport flexport
came from y combinator and it's backed
by a lot of the leading figures in
silicon valley but it's challenging a
very ancient
and sometimes backwards industry in the
shipping world so flexport is a freight
forwarder which means that it doesn't
own ships or planes or trains but it
does help its customers book space on
all those vessels to get things from the
factory to the warehouse or the store
it also does a lot of other things like
customs
insurance financing everything kind of
in that logistics chain getting
something from point a to point b for
the consumer like us
what's interesting to me about flexport
is that its ceo last year really became
sort of the face of the supply chain
problem and solutions to try to fix it
not as much was being said about his
business how big is flexport is flexport
a good business what do people think
about it and what does the existing
industry think of this silicon valley
startup that has moved in and is saying
we can do things better and faster
ryan peterson actually got his start
importing and exporting
random goods from china to arizona where
he was working with his big brother so i
was buying products in china mostly but
all over the world
buying
motorsports products we imported these
products my brother and i and another
friend of ours and sold them through the
internet so we were sort of e-commerce
entrepreneurs but also importers i felt
that we were really suffering at the
hands of the world's freight forwarders
uh nobody could tell me where my stuff
was how much it was going to cost what
all these confusing regulations were the
paperwork
i felt like i was getting ripped off um
and after a number of years of doing
some other things i built the business
selling data on imports and exports as
well
i finally came back to this problem of
like
where's the technology platform that
makes it easy to do global trade uh and
that was now eight years ago it's been
eight years since i started flexport
in january i visited the port of oakland
with ryan peterson to watch a ship get
loaded up with containers heading back
to asia
it was a slow process where you could
really see the areas where innovation
would make sense but for peterson this
is all beautiful
i argue often that i don't i think no
technology in the 20th century lifted
more people out of poverty than the
shipping container we reduced the price
of shipping by
95 maybe even 99 in some places and
that's had a tremendous upward
benefit for all of humanity it's cheaper
to buy things it's easier to find
customers all over the world businesses
can go global so it's been very powerful
but we also haven't seen a lot of
progress i mean the shipping container
was invented in the 1960s we're still
loading them one at a time
it's pretty manual operation
i
love to see real innovation here where
you could increase the throughput of
these ports
and bring machine learning into bear on
you know finding the right container at
the right moment so that drivers don't
have to wait for hours at the port gate
there's a lot of opportunity so for
technology here in this industry
shipping is obviously one of the oldest
trades in the world it's been around for
thousands of years and in recent times
shipping has been known as sort of a
family business or a business that is
not one of a lot of innovation it's one
of relationships not exactly the most
technologically savvy historically group
i assume that big companies had sort of
like advanced systems and ai and all
these things and it was only after we
got started that big company started
signing up and coming to us to talk to
us and did we realize
that in fact even the biggest companies
in the world are running these
sophisticated supply chains by emailing
microsoft excel attachments
at pdfs and making phone calls and they
really had a need
for the kinds of technology that we
build
what you need to understand about global
freight forwarding is i sometimes joke
it should be called global freight email
forwarding uh to move one container of
goods
from let's say a factory in vietnam
to a warehouse in the middle of the
united states you'll actually have as
many as 10 or 12 companies and sometimes
more
play a role uh
from the factory itself the importer the
warehouse
trucking companies in both countries
ports
customs brokerages who clear the goods
through the government agencies ocean
carriers an insurance company a bank
it's a complex coordination problem
and what flexboard has done differently
is build interfaces build software
whether that's a web interface
mobile app
and increasingly it's about apis where
software can talk to software to connect
all these parties and get them the data
they need or get us the data we need
from them
and make trade seamless so that cuts
cost
in the 2000s shipping hit historic lows
that forced these ocean carriers who've
been around for a long time to rethink
their business
so you have a lot of people thinking how
can we improve getting things onto the
ship so that ships aren't running half
empty people are actually getting their
stuff on time even if the margins and
the dollars here are not very big
that's actually great for a company like
flexport which was able to come into the
market and say hey
we don't care exactly which ship or
exactly which customer we're using but
we're going to make sure that somebody
is going to have something to load and
somebody's going to pay for that freight
to go across the ocean and that's really
what these carriers needed
in july 2020 something crazy happens
everyone starts buying stuff again and
whether it's furniture for your house or
it's you know a new home office or it's
at-home fitness equipment and that's
when suddenly prices go back up and it's
really hard to ship things on time this
is a crisis that the shipping industry
continues to deal with today is really
high prices to ship freight you know a
container that might have cost eighteen
hundred dollars to ship across the
pacific a couple years ago now can cost
eighteen thousand dollars it's pretty
tough moment to operate in our industry
i mean on the one hand it's nice people
are finally taking notice and
appreciating the fact that container
shipping is a vital part of the world's
economic infrastructure and not taking
it for granted but
prices are way up
and performance is way down most ships
are late right now a lot of transit time
failures the pandemic's really taken a
toll on the industry so customers are
upset and it's never fun to work in a
business where your customers
aren't super happy with how things are
going i think it's important to consider
flexboard also by its global impact
vexpert.org has shipped tens of millions
of units of ppe during the pandemic
fifty percent of the world's air freight
flies in the belly of passenger planes
and those were all grounded because of
the pandemic
and that's how we called united airlines
delta
and a few other airlines condor was one
of the big ones in europe and got them
to give us in some cases we paid for it
in some cases they donated and we just
stuffed all these masks in here and then
once that once we started doing this
work we became kind of a center of
gravity
and all these other
hospital networks started coming to us
it turned out they'd never imported
anything before i don't think we took a
d took a breath for like three months
where it was just like wow this is you
know 18-hour days every day
it was great because often we feel like
we know we're having an important impact
in the world well it's not that obvious
like sometimes you just ship in a
cardboard box and now it's like hey
we're saving lives right now
we can ship anything anywhere
it feels like a superpower sometime
if you can help the supply chain in some
small way we're talking multiple
trillions of dollars of innovation that
are there for the taking and i think
it's the scope the scale of this that is
maybe hard for people to appreciate
it's the kind of challenge for someone
who wants to have real global impact
[Music]
you